well Envy energy the sponsors of today's
segment offer their customers a variety
of offers through a variety of different
programs like a free refrigerator
electric dryer for example here to break
it all down from us for us from NV
Energy we have Adam Grant Adam always so
great to see you good to see you too and
I was just asking you you know is there
ever a slow time for you guys you are
always busy always something going on
right yeah there's always something on
we have a lot of programs that
especially during the holiday season we
want to get out there to a lot of our
customers who may not be in this
position to to do things that others can
so we've got some programs such as our
qualified Appliance replacement program
which really caters to the qualified
income folks we will replace your
refrigerator replace a dryer give you
opportunities to put in Energy savings
devices that will start them on their
Journey towards Energy Efficiency so
it's really cool especially this time of
year Well absolutely and that's future
NV Energy customers and and how will
that benefit them in their everyday life
and also like you mentioned saving that
energy saving money as well so the these
appliances are much more efficient than
the old appliances they may have in
their home we'll replace them for free
so this is really great because it is no
cost to these qualified customers and
there's much better efficiency on the
appliances and it'll save money on their
bill it'll save in the long run for them
and it's just hopefully it brings a nice
Christmas experience for them too
absolutely that's incredible
where's uh who who qualifies so it is
qualified income so if you go on our
website at nvenergy.com qar it has all
the income qualifications there but what
it does is is gives the opportunity to
to bring in these appliances and we have
all these other programs we work with
um
Community Partners such as Nevada hand
and or project reach Three Square to to
find these customers who maybe not be
having the the time that they need right
now so we can help them and then we're
starting now to work with veterans
groups which is really cool working with
Housing and Urban Development working
with the selective services for veterans
so for their families so we're bringing
those groups into so it's really cool
well that is incredible you guys do that
year round but especially right now
during the holidays is really important
and really quickly let's talk about the
power shift program and what that means
from MV energy so our power shift
programs is our suite of programs for
Energy Efficiency for all of our
customers from our home energy
assessments to free thermostats to these
qualified Appliance Replacements to
appliances in retail for all customers
and then the in-home assessments where
we'll come and do an assessment of your
home tell you where you can be more
efficient so bundle them all together do
that most most for free a lot of those
are free free programs helps people save
money especially time of year well I've
seen firsthand you guys come out and do
those assessments and it's really
incredible everything that you go
through so thank you to you and everyone
at MV energy for everything you do in
our community and for sponsoring today's
segment all the information on your
screen there powership by Envy energy
qualified Appliance replacement you can
call that number
855-676-9373 or visit
nvenenergy.com qar Las Vegas now we'll
be right back
[Music]